[Music]
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast livestream the Q&A section in
which we answer your super chat
questions to the best of our ability dr.
Heather huiying shall we get to it let's
do it
all right all right we'll start off with
these that came in last hour and get
through as many of them as we can and
then switch to those that come in this
hour usually in the order in which they
commit so first question is it racist to
believe that if you are of a certain
ethnicity you have the propensity to
express an allelic variant over another
I can't imagine how that would be racist
I mean first of all things like
imprinting exists it is not
inconceivable that a mechanism in a
population could trigger some kind of an
edit or some kind of epigenetic
mechanism that would bias in one
direction I mean I think the thing is
it's a simply mechanistic question no
matter what it is you know is it is it
sexist to recognize that females are on
average not as tall as males right so I
mean there's ethnicities have for
instance different amounts of melanin
Express on average different amounts of
melanin the question is do you believe
that all things that are true of humans
have reflections are reflected
differently across ethnicities and you
know we we have argued that you
shouldn't expect that some things like
gee the measure of general intelligence
should vary across races or ethnicities
but we obviously do see things like
height melanin athletic ability
maybe particular propensity and
proclivities over in ability space but
not general intelligence so no it's it
can't be racist to believe that
different ethnicities are different
which is basically what you're asking
at the mechanistic level but are they
different across all possible realm of
human difference on average we shouldn't
expect that either necessarily I'm gonna
go a little more aggressive here okay I
don't I think by and large we are overly
infatuated with a narrow genetic
interpretation of human variants and
this falls down when you get to
cognitive stuff which is why he doesn't
behave like you know the capacity to run
long distances or at high speeds or
whatever however even if it did write
let's say that whatever the mechanism
was there were differences in G between
populations would it be racist to study
them or think about them know the nature
of science is it's about the discovery
of what is factually true and frankly we
know that in the history of humans there
must have been differences between
populations and how intelligent they
were because that's the only way you get
the variance on which selection can act
to increase human intelligence which it
obviously has done it does not mean that
those differences exist in the presence
and I think we have good reason to
suspect the interpretation that says
that they do or are responsible for a
large fraction of the inequalities that
we see frankly I wouldn't know which way
to bet in terms of which populations
would be ahead because I think the
majority of intelligence is derived a
different way but facts are facts
studying them doesn't make you racist
that's right and I guess just to say one
more thing on this topic this is about
propensity to express an allelic
variants over another which is to say a
difference in size or scope of a
particular phenotypic expression
presumably but there's also differences
in variants which are harder to explain
and so don't tend to get as much play
but to take the hotbed issue that is not
the one that we are talking about right
now so not race but sex across many
domains you have the hypothesis of
greater male variability and that
hypothesis has been borne out by the
data and many things including G in fact
so we don't find for instance between
men and women within a population your
control
all the other things you would want to
control for a difference in mean
intelligence between men and women but
you do find more men at the tails of the
distribution in both directions so more
male geniuses and more male imbeciles
with the average being the same and
that's not to say that there aren't
female geniuses and let's say there
aren't female imbeciles
but that the greater male variability
hypothesis seems to be borne out across
cultures with regard to not just G not
just general intelligence but some other
things as well so a lot of the stuff
when we end up talking about differences
we tend to just default into talking
about measures of central tendency
things like averages rather than
measures of variance which is what this
greater variance hypothesis is about
yeah so put that in your pipe and don't
smoke it because that wouldn't be
ladylike yeah thanks question we need a
cricket I was waiting for it Zack I was
waiting for it yeah
in next question in the pursuit of power
and wealth the fetishization of
differences between people has been the
source of the cruelest acts we have
found no biological basis for the
concept of race racism thrives and
people not knowing this but is it racist
to keep looking for a scientific basis
of race I would ask the person who posed
this question to sit down before we
answer it because we have bad news for
you
that stuff that you've been told about
there being no biological basis for race
isn't true
now there is an argument to be made a
responsible argument to be made and I
have in fact said that race is the
bastardization of a concept that is true
right race is a problem because for
example one drop rules put you in a
racial category and one drop rule is not
a biological fact that's a sociological
imposition on a biological effect but
populations exist there are measurable
distant differences between them the
notion that has caused people to argue
that race doesn't exist is this that we
tend to find more
within races than between them that
however does not negate the existence of
populations or negate the fact that they
are distinguishable
the fact is males and females are
different and there's more range of
variation in something like height
within both categories and there is a
difference between the averages it says
nothing about the reality of those two
categories so anyway don't listen to
people who feed you garbage and
sometimes they'll feed you garbage that
you want to hear because it would make
your life simple if race didn't exist
wouldn't that be marvelous but something
that has been bastardized into race
exists I don't think there's a tragedy
in there I think it's a perfectly fine
thing and frankly the answer could be
horrifying but I've seen no reason to
expect that it will be so let's be
courageous and do this properly because
if we stack our policy and ideology on
top of a shaky foundation of pseudo
facts borrowed from pseudoscience what
we will end up with is a structure that
does not stand over the long term and
the backlash when it is understood that
we have been lied to by scientists who
wanted to tell us something that was
overly pretty will not be to our benefit
perfect next question do police unions
have anything to do with the situation
it appears to require police to
collectivise against the community
ostensibly their employer shoehorns good
and bad cops into a block that allows
qualified immunity negotiated into
contracts it's a tough question I'm sure
they're contributing in some places and
yet you know mid early mid and late 20th
century the unions were so critical for
workers rights police included that I'm
not sure how it is that you that you
walk this line you know I wouldn't say
that the answer is there for police
shouldn't be unionized because you put
police in an even riskier position with
regard to their employment status and
that's not going to make them better on
the beat all right that's that's not
going to make them into more prefer
keepers of the peace so what do we do
yeah I think the problem is this is a
classic of liberal solution making so
there is a problem the problem is that
management is inherently effectively
unionized and so if workers don't
unionize they are at a disadvantage when
dealing with management you have to
solve that problem somehow if you solve
it with a union you get a whole bunch of
other problems and so I think you know
we've seen the catastrophic collapse of
unions in the u.s. over the course of
the late 20th century especially and
there's a question about what could we
do to serve the purpose of unions which
is to give workers symmetrical power
with management basically to level the
playing field in their negotiations
without inviting some of the negative
consequences that we have seen I don't
know what the role of police unions is
you know I have zero direct information
about that certainly stands to reason
that it is contributing to a problem but
again at some level this is why we've
got to come up with a better term than
progressives but why people who believe
that we actually have to substantially
alter the system because there's too
much legacy code and it's costing us too
much see a necessity to re-evaluate
larger scale issues because if we deal
with just the symptoms it's not going to
work next question are you aware of the
rat City experiments do you think any of
these issues are related to population
density for instance bluntly put it
seems harder to ignore your neighbors
sexual proclivities when their sex life
knocks your pictures off your wall yes
oh the rat city experiments refer to mid
I think mid to mid late twentieth
century work by an ethologist animal
behaviorist who gave rats ad libitum
food and water which to say as much as
they wanted and therefore allowed them
to make more of themselves to the degree
that was possible such as they increased
the population density and then
then he watched as the society rat
society fell apart as things got super
dense this is this is er I've never
heard it called rats it's yeah rat
utopia experiments alright utopia
there's another I did look it up I can't
remember now what the sort of formal
name was my researcher was Kelvin
Calhoun yeah yeah so I actually think of
this has very little to do with what's
going on I do think that there's a
general property where back when I wrote
my paper with David Lodi on the
evolution of moral self-sacrifice I
remember somebody asked me what I was
working on and I explained to it and
they said oh when times are good people
are bad I was like okay yeah folk wisdom
once again reinvented by evolutionary
theorists but but in any case the point
is yes there is something to be said
about the ease with which we have things
even those of us who are suffering tend
to have an overabundance of food and you
know we're not we don't have enemies
spilling over our borders threatening
our well-being and also there might be
some relationship but in general I mean
that's that's a slightly different thing
isn't it that having an easy and
comfortable life and having a and being
crowded are not in Halley the same thing
you know some people seek the energy and
the amenities of a city and so those are
highly correlated but the level of
comfort and the level of crowdedness are
not are not the same measures well the
problem is I don't think we know what
those experiments mean and I don't think
we know frankly I don't even know if
they were reproduced yeah how do you
think so if they're not reproducible
then that says one thing I know from my
own work on laboratory rodents that
those animals are effectively destroyed
by the inbreeding that is done to render
their genetic backgrounds uniform and so
frankly if you look at my sout in the
wild you find a very different animal
behaviorally than the mice that you find
in the lab the mice and the lab are
mentally [ __ ]
so does the fact that you take labret I
mean you know calhoun wasn't working in
you know in in 2000 he was mid 20th
century
what were the animals he was working
with compromised in a way that affected
what happened when he over supplied them
would it happen with wild animals out
there just so many questions I want
answered and then is there any real
analogy to what we have which you know I
don't think there is I think though that
is likely that you increase population
density and behavior changes in fact I
would say it is nearly impossible that's
not true and the example that comes up
for me
maybe only because I would just like to
not talk about humans for a moment is
the Tenggara frogs on BCI by the beer
machine so let me just plug those words
here and see if a beer machine
it wasn't the beer machine no no they
were outside of a pond but wasn't the
beer machine right there no beer machine
was a hundred steps downhill in the main
lab building okay I could have sworn you
could get beer and watch these frogs
inside so we can now without taking a
hundred steps see okay so BCI is barro
Colorado Island the Smithsonian owned
research island in the middle of the
Panama Canal that was formed but the
Panama Canal was was was made it's an
island on which Brett lived for nineteen
months while he was doing his research
on bats and I was there with you for
five of those months or so and these
frogs these tangora frogs are remarkable
and very well studied in part because
they're on BCI and BCI is one of the
preeminent field stations in Latin
America and so if you if you're looking
to work in a field station this is one
of the places that you go and there is
in fact a monograph a book-length
manuscript written about the behavior of
these Tenggara frogs which really do
have fascinating behavior and I will
resist telling you anything more about
them right now but as it turns out
almost all of what was known and written
into this book about the tongue are
frogs was based on what was going on in
what's called Kodiak pond Kodak Kodak
Kodak pond based because it's where pee
take pictures right actually I don't
think the building is Kodak and I'm
wondering it's not exactly related to
Eastman Kodak can't I that's what I
thought I was the only researcher living
in this building that was already at the
point I live they're condemned due to a
termite infestation but anyway so you
don't think it's about but I mean you
just said you think it's about the
camera like I I took it I was saying
Kodiak but I took it to be the it's
about where people took pictures because
it was there it was easy to get pictures
of these frogs there because there was a
light and and there was you know a lot
to eat and so the frogs congregated in
this concrete-lined pond and they were
at high population density and therefore
they were doing a lot more engagement
over sexual selection stuff than they do
when as it turns out they were out in
the forest when there at much lower
population densities so a lot of what we
came to understand about the species of
frogs turns out to be true under the
very particular and artificial
conditions that were created by people
who had put a field station and a light
and concrete-lined thing that filled
with water and became a habitat for
frogs so a population density changes
behavior for sure
well do we know anything about what
happened in codec pond I mean the thing
about codec pond is on Barrow Colorado
which was a hilltop before the Panama
Canal filled in and I mean I arranged
all over this thing as I was doing my
work there were not natural ponds that
were like Kodak ponds so it was a very
unusual location the frogs existed in
the forests there but they definitely
existed in lower density and Kodak pond
which was you know a meter across was a
unique a unique spot but the do we know
whether or not the behaviors that were
seen in Kodak pond were distinct from
places that do have the behavior of the
same frogs and places that do have those
times much lower density well I'm sure
there are places let's say on the
mainland where water accumulates at you
know that scale and so you might have an
accumulation to our frogs that looks
like Kodak pond
if memory serves I believe it was Dave
Marsh actually I was a graduate student
who was there at the same time that you
were who did the work on BCI outside of
Kodak pond who found many but not all of
the same behaviors that had been
documented by it would have been got
Brandon Ryan I think that Kodak but not
all of them and they were also doing
some different things and I just I don't
have enough specificity now to remember
what all yeah what all is different
anyway we probably have feared too much
we have we are don't have veered yeah I
do think it's quite possible them that
the the rats in E experiments are
compromised by rats that are cognitively
compromised by a breeding protocol
that's about making a uniform genetic
background and not about preserving
their capacities which i think is a
point actually that was even mentioned
by Fineman in cargo cult science where
he talks about the fact really that
there were things I remember what
exactly his point was about rats but he
made points about psychologists
continuing to use rats for experiments
he certainly makes the point that they
used rats and experiments when other
experiments had already shown that the
rats were capable of detecting things
that the experimenters needed to
eliminate in order to to use them for
the purposes they were using them so
fascinating and Kirk occult science was
written boys seventies the latest maybe
even as early as the 60s or 50s yeah
yeah classic paper yeah all right indeed
how could the racism how could the quote
racism predates kovat be a legitimate
argument does poverty research
deficiency not predate racism given that
it existed before tribes interacted
therefore predating COBIT and racism
therefore protesting to reopen the
economy was good that is a lot of their
force yeah I think I got this okay
goodness I'm not quite tracking yet
here's the thing it can't be a
legitimate argument and the problem that
I would say a general problem is that
the dishonest brokers in our system have
a tell which is they think every
argument goes in their favor
the honest brokers all know that even if
they're right some of the arguments go
in the other direction and so what this
is is an argument that somebody offers
how could this not be useful in our
pursuit of what we want which is to
behave as we want and not be blamed for
putting people at risk during Coppa 19
now as we have pointed out it may be
that the fact that these protests are
taking place outdoors means that they
are actually safe through no proper
planning or but if that's the case then
the mocking of the protests from the
other camps two weeks earlier were
equally safe and certainly people should
have been allowed to have outdoor
ceremonies like some like funerals and
graduation ceremonies right you know if
these are safe they're the only thing
they have going for them honestly is
that they're outside yeah they people
are not being careful otherwise so some
people are masked but they're yelling
and they're close together and they're
you know they're dancing and they're
just not being safe and there's a lot of
things that we were prevented from doing
that if these are safe then all these
other things were safe too
yeah I agree so yeah it's a garbage
argument and the people who offer it
oughta know that it is and maybe they do
yeah and that's I would like to know
that yeah let's say that community
policing works perfectly wouldn't
different communities possessing
different resources ultimately require
redistributed programs that would lead
to centralization of the new community
patrols into new Metro police
departments well it depends with youth
you mean by that the thing is we've seen
this with schools right where we have
this cute little trick that we do where
we collect tax money locally for the
local school which means Beverly Hills
gets an awesome school and waas gets a
lousy school and you know that's just a
natural consequence of the way we
collect taxes and then utilize them so
that is a property that reinforces a
pattern of of opportunity and any other
is not much redistributing going on
that's my point is that the the jump in
this question is that it would
necessarily require redistribution when
in fact
it really depends on what the
foundational principles of the system
are and when the system detects that
it's done something that could be
optimized better if it were done some
different ways so I wouldn't a I mean I
guess the whole thing is kind of strange
because what are the chances that
community policing if community policing
is simply we're gonna get patrols
together and police ourselves what are
the chances that that the bad people
won't figure out that if they sign up
for the community policing that they can
go and brutalize people I mean you know
it's gonna become a protection racket
yep it sure will
yeah next question what do you think the
effect is of Twitter banning Trump's
message about unifying healing not
hatred now on YouTube
while amplifying messages by others
saying that he makes no effort to unify
understanding that no position is an
endorsement of either yes yes the whole
thing is so absurd the fact is it's not
Twitter's job to decide when we get to
hear the president and frankly I can't
stand listening to this president but I
know it's not Twitter's job to protect
me from what he's saying and frankly I
don't think that there is a limit I
don't think there's a point at which he
becomes so vile I mean I don't you know
I don't think that's his thing but if he
did yeah we would need to know about it
right away and having twitter protect us
from you know our sensitive little ears
is just so upsetting actually I don't
use my ears on Twitter very much I guess
it's my eyes Bettis them yeah but in any
case it's not Twitter's job no matter
what is going on in the White House we
need to hear about it so we can react to
it properly and yes there I don't know
about the message that actually they
shut out but it sounds like it was you
know if I if I know the man he made a
political calculation delivered an
address that paid lip-service to unity
which he is his least favorite property
because dividing us is his is his go-to
move but he said something about unity
and the fact is even if it was cynical
you have a right to judge for yourself
if they say he doesn't unify and he's
giving a message that is ostensibly
about unity then you get to make the
choice about whether or not these two
things are falsifying or if in fact the
message about unity was really about
division yeah I haven't heard of this
one either but a month or more ago don't
you know when everyone was still in
lockdown NPR and a number of TV news
services announce that they were no
longer gonna broadcast his daily press
conferences and this is insane this this
is this is absurd and it's it's just as
bad as YouTube taking down the video of
the kern county doctors or the planned a
mikvah do you know both of which we
talked about and explained why we think
there was basically nothing to these
things you know with a few exceptions
but we need to be able to go to the
source and assess for ourselves
censorship is not the answer and you
know what is the effect the effect is
gonna make the message stronger the
effect is gonna make the word not
necessary the message but the messenger
so the effect will make in this case
trump stronger it will have made the
message of planned emic and the current
county doctors stronger and that's
obviously the opposite effect that the
people who are engaging in censorship
are hoping for so maybe bastes purely on
self-interest we can make that argument
so you're doing your shooting yourself
in the foot when you do this you know
allow us to see what it is the people
are making and assess for ourselves and
allow others who we come to trust to
assess and allow us to see their
assessments twitter you're making an
ungodly messenger even worse crickets
yeah so many crickets this time of day
do you believe these public displays of
white people apologizing for their white
privilege is helpful I'm sorry but I
don't know this couldn't be less helpful
and it's not about apologies it's about
as we talked about in the initial
license it's people solving their own
problem offering Failte to the mob and
what that does is it makes the mob
stronger and it means that when somebody
says no I won't do it you're not
entitled to an apology because I haven't
done anything wrong that that person is
going to face a more ferocious enemy so
when you see somebody apologizing to the
mob
when they have not wronged the mob what
they are doing is creating a worse harm
for somebody else they are external
izing harm it's like dumping toxic stuff
into somebody's stream and then it
washes into their water supply
perfect you state that there is a deep
bench of black intellectuals your list
includes those that think like you how
do people like Abram X and Tana he see
Coates playing to your idea as ardent
intersection lists while standing in
compare I think it ends there before you
clearly have something to say here but
let me just say that our list included a
lot of people on the right actually and
included the people who we actually are
aligned with politically on the Left
people like Chloe Valder Ian Thomas
charity and Williams and then many
people on the right who we don't
particularly share politics with but
it's true that we did not have
intersectional lists like Coates and it
were Mex on our list and not a single
authoritarian oh my god right so look
Heather's Heather's absolutely right
here there are people on our list that
we disagree with as a matter of fact I
don't think there's a single person on
our list that I fully agree with I don't
fully agree with you I think that you do
all right
so the problem is that a that's a good
list be the exactly I want to add Thomas
cell and I'm probably mispronouncing his
name elder in the community economist
and Camille Camille Foster obviously
yeah and I there are others who get on
the list - I would say Dave Chappelle
belongs on the list and and hotep Jesus
so anyway what I would say is look we
don't agree with these people we agree
with them about something we agree with
them about what decency sounds like what
it's like to participate in good faith
in a conversation about things or which
you disagree and you know I don't think
taishi Coates is unrecoverable but I do
think he's taken a position that's very
hard to reason with
I would love to see him level up but
there is an obstacle to it so but I
think frankly this is just a case of of
what about ISM right well if you're
going to include all those people how
about including this one and frankly I
have said in several places that you
need to be able to shut people out who
are not acting in good faith in order
for a high quality conversation to
function because high quality
conversations are fragile conversations
and so what I want is a conversation
that contains people who are fully ready
to play and those fully ready to play
players we do have a deep bench so are
there people who might be on that bench
who I am not naming there are but you
know is that bench full of rock solid
people who are ready to go right now to
lead if they have the position to do it
from they are so that's good news yeah I
mean I would I would love to see a
conversation between for instance Tonya
hey see Coates and Chloe Valerie and you
know between him and a number of people
but I don't know I don't know that he
would come open yeah I don't know either
and I we saw Chloe Valerie offer to have
that conversation with Candice Owens and
some Tony Z goats are not the same
there definitely they are not the same
creature but nonetheless I think that's
it's the point Candice is a clearer
example of somebody who won't be
reasoned with
and I wouldn't put her on the list
either yep hypothesis stand your ground
and cancel culture our two sides of the
same coin both are a variation of I feel
threatened or offended so I'm going to
shoot or cancel you which is the
potentially bigger threat mmm excellent
question I have said before that the
extremists on on both sides are
dangerous and that while I think the
extremists on the right are outnumbered
by those on the left that the ones on
the right are better armed and so
there's this question of how much how
much damage can fewer better-armed
people do compared to more
not yet anyway as well armed people and
you know maybe that's too simplistic a
comparison but I don't know I don't know
where it falls yeah I'm a little
concerned that it's not you know there
is some relationship between these two
things but I don't think it's a close
relationship I don't think it's it's two
sides of the same coin
I must say I've been cancelled a few
times I've been shot
zero times so I don't speak from a great
deal of experience but I'd certainly
rather be cancelled than shot that said
which one stands the greater chance of
disrupting functional civilization and
replacing it with something worse cancel
culture is way more powerful than it
appears and in part because it doesn't
appear to be able to do as much harm
right just I mean just like the kinds of
violence that male criminals do is more
likely to be brutal and horrifying and
be captured on video in a terrible way
you know the average kinds of you know
crime is that women engage in for
instance is is less horrifying in that
brutal violent way but it's not to say
that there's not crime that can't do
that can't do vast civilization level
damage yeah we talked in the first hour
about the the point that I made anywhere
and everywhere that the problem that we
were seeing had very little to do with
free speech and was only tangentially
related to college campuses one of the
places that I said that was in Congress
when I was invited to testify I was on a
panel with Allison stager and and Robbie
George and anyway I told them that this
was an insidious and dangerous viewpoint
that was capable of transforming things
without your awareness I noted that at
the point the Democrats took over the
house they took down the video of that
of that testimony so I don't know how
regular it is for one party to take down
the testimony that took place under the
prior party's administration of their
body of
the Congress but nonetheless I was
struck by the fact that there did seem
to be a tendency on the left to try to
obscure this point
and anyway yeah that it is a a high
level and dangerous process that we
should pay attention to but definitely
if you got to choose between getting
shot and getting cancelled go as
canceled okay we're gonna try to get
through at least the next boy let's just
try five it's tough again many more
questions that we can get to and we
appreciate the questions and the support
hypothesis a cab all cops are bastards
is literally false but acting as if it
were true increases one's chances of
coming out of an encounter with the
police unharmed can we replace it with
something that serves the same purpose
without side effects how do you figure
that
ACAB increases the chances that you're
not gonna be harmed by a cop you just
told them that they're a bastard no
matter what they do well no I mean I
think I think you know let's imagine
that this isn't something that you are
you're yelling at them and graffitiing
on buildings but that you have it in
your head that you have it in your head
that please detain juris and I you know
I as I understand it you know I yes it's
not how I grew up because I because my
skin is white and I'm female and so this
was really not something that I had to
to worry about as much but you know I as
I understand it in some african-american
families this is exactly what is what is
taught right no not not that not a cab
but assume that you're not going to come
out of a out of an interaction with
police well and so avoid police
interactions if you can I'm having none
of it I'm having absolutely none of it
and here's why when we participated in
Occupy I made a point of talking to the
cops which got me branded as a traitor
because I was told all cops were
bastards in therefore am I talking to
them was counterproductive what I
learned from talking to them was
unambiguous
some cops are bastards others are not
here's the problem
and all cops are bastards mentality
results in no crossing the line now as
we've talked about before those of us
who are not cops tend not to circulate
amongst cops we don't know them they are
a monolith and they don't tend to know
us what is essential essential
everywhere where bad policing is a
possibility what is essential is that
the populace is understood to be
composed of humans by the police and the
police are known to be composed of
humans by the populace that's the thing
that takes the hair trigger and lowers
it so that it is not so likely to break
out into violence jeez oh it's not B
it's all cops are a risk to you any cop
that you don't know might be that is
decent advice you don't know until
you've spoken to a cop but the
possibility that that cop is actually on
your side is also there and one of the
things that I got in talking to this DHS
officer was that he felt a an obligation
that I did not expect to see to protect
the protesters even to protect the
rioters he understood his job was to
defuse the situation without any money
being harmed and he talked to me about
the pride with which certain past
incidents had been resolved without harm
and this was a badge of honor and so the
idea that one of these things might
break down into violence that's a
failure to the extent that you are aware
that the person on the other side
doesn't want to engage in violence
they're not you may be looking for an
excuse for violence but they're not that
is an important piece of understanding
and all cops are bastards is absolutely
toxic as I said on Twitter several days
ago
it is accelerant being poured on this
fire
next question is about a movie that I
don't know light-hearted question what
are your thoughts in the movie the
Hebrew hammer I don't know it do you
know it no I'm okay
tempted to say something glib but given
that I don't know yes I probably oughta
my tongue until I do can you clarify the
main flaws that you see in the BLM black
lives matter movement any ideas for how
we support the movement while addressing
the flaws that it can be more effective
well okay here's the thing first of all
black lives matter is an idea and black
lives matter is a movement the movement
is headed by people I don't trust
they have done things in setting out
their mission that reveal that they are
up to something other than pointing out
the fact that black lives are
undervalued
in our society which I fully believe
they are so the fact of the movement
being headed by people who appear to be
up to things other than the stated
mission is in and of itself sufficient
but I would just point out as an example
the fact that BLM is officially
anti-israel puts people well I think it
puts any decent person in a predicament
why is it that in order to take a
position on the undervaluing of black
lives in America one also has to take a
position on the Khan various conflicts
with Israel it makes no sense and so
it's it's a Trojan horse that smuggles
in this one concept that's unrelated
with another concept and the whole idea
is you're supposed to sign up based on
the hashtag and anytime somebody wants
me to sign up based on the hashtag my
question is can I see the fine print I
want to see the fine print because I
have a feeling there might be something
in there that I don't know I'm signing
up for yeah I guess I would just add I
agree with all of that if the second
part of the question is any ideas for
how we support the movement while
addressing the flaws I don't I don't
want to support the movement I want to
support the idea the concept and it had
because it has been
taken over by this hashtag and by this
movement that is called itself this
thing it is actually I think doing far
more harm than good
it is it is almost certainly at this
point given what is going on in
America's streets forcing people some
people who were maybe a little bit on
the fence back into a somewhat more
racist position because the violence
that is being done in the name of black
lives matter when it is the vast vast
vast majority of people including black
people who want none of it who have no
interest in any of it and what's more I
have not seen leadership come out of it
that does any of the things that are
needed it has not basically shut down
the rioting and looting so that you have
a protest that can be taken seriously so
anyway that's on that's on BLM and if it
reforms itself fine but until it does
it's a compromised movement that is
taking this energy and directing it
counter productively like it's one more
thing it doesn't it doesn't seem to
allow for dissent which is just picking
up on what you said and so any movement
that does not tolerate dissent is not
one that I want to encourage anyone to
be part of there there has to be dissent
allowed or else it's or else it's not
worthy
tomorrow we'll switch is it useful to
think about evil and dysfunction as an
evolving mind virus with the risk that
certain ways of addressing it results in
something analogous to drug resistance
should we think in terms of social media
distancing yes we should yeah so there's
a lot wrapped up in there and it's gonna
take me 20 minutes of quiet time to
figure out yeah exactly what I think but
I mean the second question should we
think in terms of social media
distancing yeah let's just say there are
things about our social media
environment that have radically changed
essential elements of how things are
done and we don't know what the
consequences are I would argue that the
fact of our
would be leader is being trapped in the
gig economy could well be a completely
natural and accidental outgrowth of the
way business model interfaces with
influencer status yada yada yada but it
leaves us in a position where we are
lacking the thing we need most which is
leaders empowered elite so I don't know
that social media distancing will do it
but certainly thinking about the
downstream consequences of this novel
media environment is essential and we
are overdue to have that conversation in
earnest yeah so the next two questions
well you you might have a quick answer
in the first one but I want to come back
to them when we have one more time where
I may even just put a put a post up on
medium or something one is thank you all
for the sustain a wonderful content I'm
in awe of how you think if you were to
suggest one book or otherwise to help
one further develop the critical
thinking skills what would it be
you have something yeah that's gonna
seem left field but Guns Germs and Steel
you need to understand that human beings
aren't involved in the game that the
human beings as individuals don't know
they're aren't involved in and
understanding that means that you are
empowered if you can transpose what you
learned from Guns Germs and Steel on to
you know the streets of American cities
as they break down into these tribal
battles you'll be way ahead that's great
and then the second one thank you for
continuing to make consistently
interesting content what vaccines or
other precautions would you recommend
are consider required for traveling to
Central and South America so this is
this was part of the job that I made for
myself and I was running study abroad
trips
it depends precisely on where you're
going and not just what country but what
latitude and whether or not you're in
urban areas or I mean not just what
latitude but what altitude you know the
lowland jungles are where you're more
likely at the mosquito vector diseases
etc I'd be happy to share some of the
you know requirements that I had and
advise for particular curricula for
particular places that we went but in
short if you're going to be traveling in
in South America and going to the
lowlands and getting away from cities
you are likely to need malaria
prophylaxis although not necessarily
depending on where you're going and you
may need yellow fever vaccination not
cholera because it's no good and a few
others as well not color because it's no
good and you're not gonna die of it
anyway yeah but as I say the vaccination
the the color a vaccine isn't very good
and cholera doesn't turn out to be a
killer of people who are wealthy enough
to be traveling from the US to Central
and South America yeah so yeah it isn't
a just go to your you know travel nurse
and just accept all the shots they want
to put in your arms you actually can do
a much better job than that but there
will be there will be shots that you'll
need in order to pretty much guarantee
that you'll stay healthy you will
however be surprised at how many places
I mean even the deep into the Amazon
where we just went did not require
malaria prophylaxis against wasn't an
issue there right I mean the CDC's
recommendations are you absolutely need
it but when you talk to the people on
the ground there they say we actually
it's you know it's in locally recorded
history sort of 30 40 years there's not
been a case by their vivax or falciparum
malaria and so none of us who live here
are taking the prophylaxis okay so the
final thing to say is that in general
going into such environments people fear
the wrong stuff the thing that's really
gonna get you might be tree falls or
rapidly changing water conditions that
cause you to drown unexpectedly the
snakes are less of a danger than you
think
the malaria is a less of a danger than
you think and you know there are places
where these things are key hazards but
be prepared that the thing that's gonna
get you is the thing you aren't
bothering to think about yeah right it's
something something different that's
right okay on to the super check
questions from this our first so you've
marked it here Zack this line yeah looks
like right how does one explain to
friends how dangerous vote blue no
matter who is especially considering the
issues blue areas or blue areas or
having due to their policies I'm not
naive to read state issues by the way
how do you explain it to friends um well
it depends it really depends how smart
your friends are and unfortunately they
need to be pretty darn smart to get over
this one but here's the thing that I
would just start with okay if the point
is that Trump is so dangerous and so
frightening that you have no choice but
to vote for the thing that's being
offered as the alternative to him no
matter how decrepit and uninteresting
and clownish clownish for example if
that's the idea
then how do you address the fact that
Hillary Clinton actually used surrogates
in the press to advance Donald Trump's
candidacy because she he was her chosen
adversary he was the adversary of choice
because she thought she could beat him
easily at the polls and so he was
advanced as a Pied Piper candidate so no
matter how much you dislike Trump I
don't understand how this doesn't end up
on blues bill and if blue is doing this
to you right if Trump makes you insane
and blue it was advancing Trump then the
whole the game is up you can see it it's
right in front a the whole system is
corrupt and insane it's delivered you a
divisive president on the one hand and
an empty alternative on the other and
get the hell over it and if your friends
can't hear that find better friends I
love your rants alright it was great
next question do you feel the extreme
Kovich shutdown followed by the seeming
rapid endorsement of the riots from
elites exposes an authoritarian ulterior
motive I don't think so
it's not beyond the realm of possibility
but I don't see those two things as
linked in a conspiratorial like way
inherently I think we have to be open to
any possibility here one thing that this
DHS officer said to me he said so many
interesting things that were really
worth remembering one thing is he said
and I asked him what he really thought
was going on he said I think we're
getting played and he meant all of us
and I said by whom and he said you know
I'm really not sure but I do have the
sense that we are being ushered towards
something now I don't know how to take
that exactly that could mean almost
anything but there is a way in which the
one-two punch of covered 19 followed by
this unrest and rioting presumably this
is an organic sequence but the problem
is we have gigantic adversaries who have
their own interests with respect to
where we are and they pay attention to
world events and I certainly wouldn't
put it past them to take advantage of a
naturally occurring event and seed
things into our discussion that would
cause us to harm ourselves I mean you
know frankly I'm upset to see the
protesters and rioters be declared
terrorists I think it's an abuse of the
concept and it's not a good fit and
there's a reason it's being done which
is that it causes a suspension of the
Constitution with respect to them on the
other hand terrorists what they do is
they take advantage of psychological
biases in order to get you to harm
yourself right a terrorist organization
is not big enough to hurt you so what it
does is it takes advantage of you know
things deeply in your nervous system
that can be triggered with very
frightening things that they can cause
you to see and then your reaction to it
is what does the harm it's like a bee
that stings you that bee isn't in a
position to kill you but your own immune
reaction to it might and so that
overreaction is a weapon in the wrong
hands do our enemies know that this was
a powder keg ready to go off and you
know if if we're worried about the
manipulating elections we ought to be
worried about them taking advantage of
things that cross our news cycle and
could potentially be weaponized by
ceding certain elements do you have
thoughts on the anti-lynching bill and
its implications Rand Paul stopped it
because he was worried about it being
too broad allegedly Thanks
I know almost nothing about this I can't
say much I know very little in fact most
of what I know is contained in the
question but I do have the sense of why
do we need an anti-lynching bill right
am i for lynching anybody who has the
slightest bit of knowledge about me
knows that I am not remotely for
lynching in fact you know that I also
think that the Evergreen situation could
have resulted with my lynching Rozelle
today in my lynching so anyway I'm all
for us not having lynching on the other
hand it's very much against the law
we don't have an epidemic of lynching in
fact it's a long time that one has to go
back to find an instance of it and so I
do have the sense that the fact that our
legislative apparatus is focused on this
is conspicuous and I certainly have my
problems with Rand Paul on the other
hand I do not like the idea that there's
a bill that everybody has to sign on to
to do away with lynching because we all
don't like it and Rand Paul is now
suspect because he stood in the way I
don't know why he stood in the way but
would I be shocked to find out that you
know he was taking a principled stand
against a manipulative bill I wouldn't
be shocked at that this looks like a
comment that maybe ends midstream so I
will read it as it's written here in
Brazil the SJW is basically copy
everything that goes on in the u.s. they
try to see society in black or white
terms where race has traditionally been
a spectrum and a person gets whiter as
she and Rich's absolutely this means a
person gets whiter she gets richer well
so yeah so there's this metaphorical
whiteness that is correlated with wealth
and that's actually how I understand
I've only been in Brazil once but I I
studied Brazilian culture a bit in
college and that's how I understand it
as well that's too bad what you're
saying about it basically mirroring the
you know the extreme left mirroring
what's going on in the u.s. of course it
also seems like Belsen arrow is kind of
a mirror for for Trump in many ways from
what I've seen worse mortally yeah
just in because I can I can see the
effects he's having on the Amazon and
know enough about what is true of the
Amazon to know that he's not telling the
truth but I guess it's not surprising
then that if you've got this pretty a
pretty right-wing populists character
that he came in on a way of extreme
student leftism that doesn't that does
not that he was sort of an imagined
antidote to that isn't that surprising I
guess yeah shame but not surprising
bolson ro is a bit like you put Trump
through a charnel-house mirror I don't
have to look up charnel-house I think
it's not good
I might have to look it up too okay next
question
mm-hmm Heather can you share your
experience with body work after your
boating accident it saved my life after
my car wreck but I'm afraid to talk
about it because it's often labeled as
new-age pseudoscience
yeah I'll say just a couple words here
and I actually have thought about this
sufficiently that it's on a list of way
too many topics of things that I might
actually write an entire book about at
some point there's a lot of whoo out
there there's a lot of new-age
pseudoscience out there but there's also
a tremendous amount that is not
particularly sanctioned by the
mainstream sort of m.d world that is
that I feel like it's saved save my life
to that the ability to which I've been
able to come back and feel almost
entirely intact after an all body
wreckage four years ago now has been
extraordinary and some of the forms of
body work that I didn't know existed
or I'd heard of but barely knew what
they were before that have proved
remarkable are something called strain
counter strain therapy which emerges
from the osteopathic tradition
craniosacral all sorts of osteopathic
stuff structural integration boy there's
there's some more that I'm not thinking
of at the moment
yeah I'll have a lot more to say about
it but in short the skeleton is is easy
to look at and measure and point to
because it doesn't seem to move or
change much once baby we become adults
because it's mammals we have something
called determinate growth and it just
stops growing it's the soft tissue that
is actually necessary for most of the
healing and even though I was I was
broken at the skeletal and soft tissue
level pretty much all over it is getting
all of the not just skeletal muscle and
ligaments and tendons back in place but
also the and maybe especially the fascia
which is the sort of thin sheath of
muscle covering a lot of skeletal muscle
between the skeletal muscle and the skin
that is really important to get an
entire body working in an integrated way
again so for my part I would say we
don't tend to get more limber and
capable as we get older once we reach
adulthood but the change in what you are
capable of post-accident
has definitely gone in the direction of
better and better as you have engaged
these things so whatever the explanation
for how they function is there is a lot
to be said for the fact that medicine
which does so much harm the way it is
currently constructed we would have
looked at you and said well this is
damaged let's manage the symptoms of it
late forties you're just gonna be
senescent now right as you know would
have prescribed stuff to manage pain and
things like that and much better to give
your body the opportunity to heal and to
potentially increase the degree to which
you can I mean the fact is it's not
rocket science you've got connective
tissues that are frozen in the wrong
place because an accident or something
and they are involved in you know
keeping things from moving against each
other and then freeing those things back
up will have a positive impact but just
as you have unambiguously seen my
reaction to wheat and you know it's real
because you know that when I end up with
wheat that I don't know I've had
symptoms come as I'm short ly there
after I've seen
dramatic improvement in what you're
capable of you you're not back to where
you were
hmm but you are headed in that direction
even as you're getting older so anyway
there's a lot to be said there but the
pattern is unambiguous for somebody who
knows you as well as anyone and spends
almost all my time with you yeah I guess
but maybe just two more things to this
now and I you know I could spend years
talking about this some of the
extraordinary practitioners that I have
found and some of whom I continue to
work with who did not know me I think I
didn't know any of them before the boat
accident so they didn't know what kind
of a person I was but they've all
they've many of them have spoken to I
can see you know your athletic miss
coming out that you know I was an
athlete and and highly athletic but that
was completely invisible for months to
years after the Botox and I just
couldn't move and the other thing is
that it really completely depends to
some degree on the tradition and the the
particular things that that the person
who was working on you the bodywork
person thinks they know but it's really
particular to the person themselves the
protection the practitioner and so one
thing that my strain chemistry and
therapists up in Olympia I used to say
she's brilliant she's I think mostly
retired now so I'm not going to share
her name here because she's just not
seeing patients anymore she was trying
to train someone new and she was having
a hard time doing it so she was
completely schooled in the science of
why what she was doing was working but
she also had the intuition with her
hands that she could she could put hands
on another body and feel what she
understood from science to be true but
also knew what to do through intuition
and it's that combination of things and
I think this is true across pretty much
all domains not just body work that
understanding the why and the what which
is to say the science of what it is that
you're doing and what it is you're
trying to do in combination with
trusting your instincts assuming that
you've got a good enough background to
have good instincts and running with
your intuition and especially when
the science and your intuition and the
compassion that comes from intuition
come together that's when you have a
practitioner who really can do amazing
things and and help a body heal yep
final thing I would say is I have also
seen you go to things and come back and
say I don't think it's real so you know
I have the fact that you say these
things work for you tells me
unambiguously there's something to it
doesn't mean it will work for everybody
but it means that for what you had going
on it was the right thing yeah yeah I've
definitely run into some some whew and
okay well that was $60 or you know in 45
minutes and I'll ever get back but not
going back something like that
okay some nurses next question some
nurses may be experiencing vicarious
trauma and are unable to think until the
waters are calmed is it possible to
implement active listening and mirroring
skills to calm the waters first I'm not
sure what the first is in reference to I
think if we take it as a comment I think
I agree that I think health health
providers across all aspects if they've
been involved in treating kovat 19 are
experiencing trauma likely and may not
be in their best frame of mind in order
to respond rationally to everything
that's going on I also think you know
PTSD functioning the way it does that if
and when this is over mm-hmm there's
going to be another crisis for them
because going back to normal is it
should be straightforward but it isn't
for deeply human reasons right good hi
Brett how long do you think it'll take
to integrate evolution into the medical
study curriculum and do you think it is
likely to prolong or shorten the time
needed to qualify thank you for these
podcasts that's from twinkle catnap
let's put it this way if the medical
establishment can't get its act together
by 2300 I'm out
20300 do say yeah I'm sorry was reading
another question I don't know I mean
I've almost given up on medicine getting
properly evolutionary look medicine
should become properly evolutionary I
don't know 50 years ago
yeah the evolutionary stuff was
sophisticated enough to to be properly
very at least they should have responded
when Williams and Nestle wrote I said
how or why we get sick why we get so why
we get sick in the early 90s or so so
thirty almost thirty years ago
no it's inexcusable and the the amount
of harm that is done because doctors
somehow skip the Darwinism is appalling
and as I will keep telling you it's as
bad as it is in medicine it's even worse
in dentistry
there's just no awareness of this being
a Darwinian landscape and yet we're just
harming people yeah it's the second part
of this question is fascinating though
do you think if if if somehow
evolutionary thinking broke into the
medical curriculum as it obviously
should have do you think it's like they
prolong or shorten the time needed to
qualify like what it would would
evolutionary thinking perhaps just
because you know the the knee-jerk
response would be well you're adding
something more force Kirsch is gonna
make the course work longer but might'n
it basically cut the Gordian knot on a
lot of this stuff and allow a
simplifying like you just like carry the
water like oh okay now we have such a
more simple foundation and yes your
specialty fields are still going to
require all of that work but in terms of
understanding the body as a holistic
system that has emergence to it and that
can be understood with a few simple
things from which you can you can build
from first principles it's much simpler
than doing this rote memorization that
is how most of we understand the medical
curriculum to be taught in part because
some number of the people who we were
teaching we're effectively going into
pre-med and so you know I did a lot of
teaching of comparative anatomy labs and
and such and see I never I
only used I used lab manuals because
that's where the diagrams of the cats
and the sharks of such art but I didn't
use the textbooks but I got them for
free because they were trying to get me
to force the students to buy them and
the texts are crazy like these texts
could be the texts could be two thirds
at least the length that there they are
if they just took an evolutionary
approach therefore I think that medical
curriculum could as well oh I agree can
we call this Occam's scalpel yes all
right
you can we are agreed hour and three
minutes okay let's let's just do three
more I don't know what they are I just
chose three because why not and then
we'll sign off rat Park question mark
brusque Alexandre with the rats who
chose to use or not use opiates based on
how their surroundings are configured so
that's something different so that I
think is in reference to the earlier
question where that was my first
reaction to that oh is he talking about
rat Park so this these two different
things there's rat utopia which is this
work done giving rats
adlib food and water until they became
overpopulated and then society fell
apart sounds like utopia to me and the
population crashed but again we don't
know if this isn't replicate right and
then there's the rat Park which I think
we've actually referenced this at some
point earlier in these live streams
which was basically I'm not sure this
was the intention but I understand it to
be a test of the hypothesis that opiates
simply produce addiction that opiates
are addictive and therefore if you give
organisms opiates mammals that have the
receptors for them they will become
addicted and what they found was you
give a rat in a cage with nothing to
play with opiates and sure enough he's
gonna keep on hitting the trigger and
get addicted but if you give a rat
opiates who's in a cage that also has
some other rats and some shoe toys I
don't know what rats want but yeah if
you if you if you enrich the rats
environment they're much less likely to
be addicted they'll try it and maybe
they'll go back and try it you know on
the weekends I don't know but but
they're much less likely to become
addicted and I see the rat affair
we still aren't drinking oh we're still
not drinking yet rien dodging asleep
producing substances that are producing
that effect yeah okay second to last
question etymological correction the
meme blank blank - electric Boogaloo yes
I can't remember what movie it was but
anyway that's how the question reads the
animal electrical correction the meme
quote blank blank - electric Boogaloo
originated in the 80s movies the last
two years it found civil war - electric
Boogaloo and then more generalized
Boogaloo covering unrest so I don't
remember exactly what you said earlier
about the hiss I said the doctrine and
actually this officer told me some of
this so the idea is Boogaloo has
different meanings in different contexts
and the etymology has to do with these
films and obviously they are borrowing a
term from a Musical and dance reference
50 is 56 days like that certainly James
Brown exactly yeah
not thanks for the correction I what I
would love to know is how many different
usages are currently in fashion is the
idea that this is a race war code is
that a 4chan joke that they are playing
on us and it doesn't really mean that is
that really happening and their fringe
element that are trying to take over an
otherwise legitimate thing is is the
thing mostly illegitimate and it's been
their legitimate forces trying to move
in the right direction yeah it's really
hard to tell it's just like this
question of what percentage of the bad
actors that we're seeing on the streets
right now what percentage of them are
the riders and the looters and what
percentage of them are the police I
don't know and no one knows okay last
question is it possible that youths who
are being drawn to riot alongside the
anarchist some quotes are becoming
radicalized by having witnessed the
sickening examples of police brutality
against protesters this week yeah yeah I
mean that's that's part of the point
yeah the point is to
predict that the police are brutal to
force them to be brutal and to say I
told you so and I think we are all
suffering from it because if you look at
the films of you know these flash bangs
and CS gas and smoke bombs and pepper
and all of those other things it does
look brutal and the real question is do
you understand the context and no doubt
there are many cases in which these
things are being deployed needlessly but
is that the average case I don't know
and you really have to see the entire
context and unfortunately as much as the
ubiquity of cell phone cameras means
that we get a chance to look at all
sorts of stuff we wouldn't be able to
see directly otherwise it also puts an
awful lot of power in the hands of those
who decide where the clip starts and
where it stops and so beware yeah well
there are a lot of a lot more questions
here and I'm sure many of them are good
but I think we are at the end the next
time the audience is going to see you
it's going to be in a perhaps this
premiere event that you're gonna put up
with how do you pronounce his name
you read diggin diggin URI day gonna
fine fine fella and we had a very good
discussion so anyway please consider
tuning in for that and one day at some
point probably mid day yeah I will
release it Monday partly it's
complicated because I would love it if
URI could be there and he's on Moscow
time which is I think 10 hours ahead
well yeah Zack is pointing out that none
other than Eric Weinstein has posed a
question here so I think maybe we should
we should do that one before we sign off
wait this is wild because I did not
actually know that Eric Weinstein was a
different person than you I don't know
people tell me this all the time they
tell me I didn't know you and Eric were
two different people yeah I don't see it
and Eric if you're watching I imagine
the PIA doesn't see it either so I can
I've always been able to tell that you
guys are different really you guys
realize that Eric is like 6 3 and I'm
like 5 10 so there's that and Eric's
hair is like twice as crazy I have a
beard there's lots to go on here I'm
dressed like a border collie
[Music]
okay now we have to take this seriously
how do we avoid Erik asks how do we
avoid the BLM takeover redirection
harnessing and weaponization of all the
general anger that has been building
including legitimate racial anger so
this this is this is the better version
of the question that we addressed with
regard to you know how do you how do you
how do you turn BLM into the movement
you want to be as sort of it's like like
know we put BLM aside yeah so this this
is a of course Erik oyster nails it yep
this is go he's now so yeah here's the
thing dude consider my formulation all
of our would-be leaders are trapped in
the gig economy that is not going to
work out because the gig economy has
certain dynamics to it where people can
click away right leaders don't have that
problem now you can decide you've lost
your faith in a leader but that's a much
more difficult process right it's like
you know it's like a divorce so what we
need to do is figure out how to take the
leaders and I swear there are a bunch of
them who are perfectly positioned and
ready to go we've got to figure out how
to put those people in a position where
they are understood to be leaders and
not understood to be producers of
content I believe that is the may be the
only thing necessary in order to
redirect this is it too late I don't
know I surely hope not all right
great question bro
maybe we're there I think we're there
alright well this was great I really
enjoyed it and look forward to the next
one so please tune in for me and Yuri
Dagon on Monday and stay tuned for
future content like subscribe comment
spread it around if you thought this was
good
and in the meantime before we see you
next stay safe
you